Dear kitten,...
...I see you've noticed the new addition to our home.
No, you're not crazy.
It is calling to you and it does want you to destroy it.
Don't be timid, I know what you're thinking.
This must be some sort of a trap the humans have set for us.
But they actually encourage us to scratch these.
That's crazy.
I remember the first time I encountered the vertical carpet.
Of course, they were much bigger back then,...
...enormous pillars reaching endlessly into the sky.
Without any sort of guidance or training,...
...I began climbing the first of the towers.
Though exhausted, I reached deep down inside...
...and found the power to ascend the third tower.
And when I arrived at the summit,...
...there was a ceremony held in which the collar of courage was bestowed on me...
...for my valor in the face of extreme danger.
Those were the good old days.